si tiene una condición en su cuello que
hace presión en su médula espinal o
nervios espinales su médico puede
recomendar El reemplazo del disco
cervical la columna vertebral en su
cuello llamada columna cervical tiene
siete huesos llamados vértebras
la parte frontal de cada vértebra es
llamada cuerpo vertebral excepto por la
primera vértebra
entre la mayoría de vértebras hay una
amortiguación suave de cartílagos
llamado disco
invertebrado la parte posterior de cada
vértebra tiene una sección curva llamada
el arco
vertebral salvo por la primera vértebra
cada arco vertebral tiene una proyección
ósea llamada proceso
espinal en cada lado del proceso espinal
hay una pieza plana de hueso llamada
lámina el arco vertebral de la vértebra
rodea y protege su médula
espinal una columna de tejido nervioso
frágil que conecta su cerebro con otros
nervios en su
cuerpo su médula espinal pasa a través
de un espacio cerrado llamado canal
vertebral el cual está formado por arcos
vertebrales de su vértebra
con el tiempo su columna cervical puede
desarrollar problemas como el encog del
disco un disco herniado o
roto o crecimientos óseos en su vértebra
llamado espolones
óseos estos cambios pueden reducir el
canal vertebral Y colocar presión en su
columna espinal o los nervios que
ramifican de
ella la presión puede provocar dolor en
el cuello y rigidez o dolor
entumecimiento y debilidad en sus brazos
o
manos antes de la cirugía se colocará
una vía intravenosa o
IB usted puede recibir antibióticos por
vía intravenosa para disminuir la
posibilidad de
infecciones se le colocará anestesia
general para que esté inconsciente y sin
dolor durante la
cirugía se le insertará un tubo
respiratorio por la boca y la garganta
para ayudarlo a respirar durante la
operación
su cirujano hará una incis en su
cuello la parte de la columna cervical
que contiene el disco daado Será
expuesta su cirujano retirará todo el
disco
daado luego su cirujano retirará toos
espolones
óseos se cortarán los cuerpos
vertebrados encima y debajo del disco
removido para permitir la colocación de
un disco artificial
finalmente su cirujano insertará el
disco artificial el cual puede ser
colocado en su lugar con tornillos el
disco artificial está diseñado para
preservar el movimiento normal en este
nivel de su
columna la incisión de su piel puede ser
cerrada con pegamento quirúrgico o cinta
de sutura
cutánea después de la cirugía se le
retirará el tubo respiratorio y se le
trasladará a la de recuperación para
controlarlo le darán medicamentos contra
el dolor si fuese necesario se le dará
de alta del hospital dentro de uno o dos
días después de la
cirugía